voilà friot tout cela que tu y es a pris
tout cela pour l'afrique
ça promet
[Musique]
alors une auxiliaire de puériculture
elle peut travailler dans plusieurs
domaines toujours dans le médico-social
donc en crèche en maternité en néonat
aura la pmi protection maternelle
infantile
[Musique]
le suivi d enfance à la pmi se fait de 0
à 6 ans
donc on va les suivre dès la sortie de
la maternité donc nous les auxiliaires
de puériculture et les puéricultrices
ont généralement les suites de 0 à 3 ans
ensuite l'infirmière prend le relais
généralement des à l'entrée dès qu'il
rentre à l'école
la firme vient de l'infirmière de paix m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous on les observe de perry culture et
les puéricultrices à tour de rôle on
fait les pré consultation avant le
médecin donc on voit les enfants avant
donc on mesure leurs paramètres vitaux
on donne déjà les conseils en
allaitement voit un petit peu comment
l'enfant l'enfant grandit donc on fait
les mesures la pesée
le périmètre crânien aussi
[Musique]
oui
essayez de débriefer le plus possible
pour que le médecin elle elle fasse
vraiment un examen plus poussé et
qu'elle perd moins de temps c'est
surtout pour éviter que les
consultations dure trop longtemps
non on fait surtout de la prévention au
niveau de la santé sur les vaccins sur
l'alimentation on donne aussi des
conseils sur l'allaitement
[Musique]
vous êtes toujours mais avec mon
internet
oui ça se passe bien pendant sept mois
et demi donc ça veut dire que l'ia elle
peut commencer à manger
oulala je vais dans six mois
donc vous avez commencé dès petit coup
de midi
est ce qu'elle se tient un petit peu
tout seul type
vraiment c'est la plaine aussi
mais la toile derrière la tête je suis
sur 7 47 et nick
mais
très bien et la taille aussi bien
proportionné ça va donc ça sert à rien
on a aussi un rôle de psy au niveau
psychologique où les parents on doit
être beaucoup à l'écouté des parents
surtout des mamans à la sortie de
maternité les mamans primipares donc
c'est celle qui ont eu un premier enfant
sont souvent perdus ou qu'elles ont
besoin de conseils de besoin d'être
accompagnés dans les soins on travaille
aussi en collaboration avec la
puéricultrice donc on a aussi un elle
joue aussi un rôle aussi à jouer
là-dedans où elles vont plus elle
s'orienter sur dvd qui sont avec en plus
deux pistes de spécificités par exemple
les prématurés
oui ça va nécessiter des soins et des
conseils un petit peu plus particulier
allez montre moi on est des vrais
musiciens c'est propre à la réunion où
les auxiliaires de puériculture peuvent
se déplacer à domicile je sais qu'en
métropole ça se fait pas trop
c'est plutôt les puéricultrices qu'ils
le font c'est surtout une question de
facilité pour les mamans qui viennent de
sortir de maternité qui sont fatigués et
qui n'ont pas forcément la possibilité
de se déplacer tout de suite en pmi à la
sortie à la sortie de maternité
[Musique]
toi
deux points
[Musique]
on participe aussi aux la peau lieu
d'accueil parents enfants
donc si un lieu où les parents peuvent
venir avec leur enfant notre rôle dans
les lap et avec les éducatrices de
jeunes enfants donc on a un rôle de
collaboration donc généralement elle est
la directrice avec qui on va l'aider à
monter le projet et ensuite on va faire
nous les ateliers les animations
[Musique]
dis donc ça permet aussi de parler de
parentalité nous aussi de veiller à la
la maltraitance donc on a aussi un rôle
de prévention au niveau de la
maltraitance au niveau des enfants
on arrive à détecter parfois des
maladresses je vais appeler ça des
maladresses parce que parfois c'est pas
c'est de la maltraitance mais des fois
c'est la maladresse parce qu'elles ne
savent pas faire ou parce qu'elles
savent pas comment faire donc on va
orienter les mamans pour 20 pour l'heure
pour les amener à essayer de les guider
un petit peu dans l'éducation des
enfants parce qu'on a surtout un rôle de
parent un groupe de parentalité et de
prévention aussi de la maltraitance dans
lé là
robin
[Musique]